What do we do with our ego is helped us climb the dominance hierarchy is secure
a mate.
Why then should we keep looking for a mate and how to curtail that instinct?
Well,
I think part of the way that you curtail that inks in state is that you have,
you have this sort of life that you would have with a mate.
The question is what's the purpose of pair bonding?
And one of the fundamental purposes of pair bonding while there's a couple one,
is that it solves the sexual access problem so that you don't have to continue
to obsess about who you're going to be within and,
and,
and where and how.
And so you can get on with other elements of your life.
But I mean with,
with your mate,
you have to decide,
well,
what does it mean that you're now together?
You know,
you're there,
there's companionship obviously,
and friendship and their shared interests.
You have to decide what they are.
And I would say that you should continue dating your partner at least once a
week or perhaps twice a week because otherwise the romance goes out of your
life.
But then also you have to decide about children and eventually about
grandchildren because you know you're going to get old and you're going to get
older and more mature and children are a huge part of life and they get a bad
rap,
which is really unfortunate because you know,
maybe I'm,
I'm different in this regard.
Perhaps I am to some degree,
but I never regretted having kids for even one second because there are so mean.
All of a sudden you have an intimate relationship with new people that is as
close as any relationship that you've ever had.
You have the opportunity to make that relationship as pristine as you possibly
can.
I mean,
there can be a lot of catastrophe involved in it,
but it's a great opportunity and there's just nothing wrong with having some
additional people that love you,
you know?
And so what you do is you turn your attention to the issues of maturity and
you're tuning your attention away from the issues of being a juvenile.
And you do that partly by knowing that it's actually better to do.
So.
You know,
there's nothing more absurd than the 40 year old 20 year old.
It gets ugly and there's something like,
there's something like spoiled milk about it.
It goes off and you have to gracefully accept the challenges of each stage of
life and things work a lot better when you do that much,
much better.
And you also have to,
I would say,
work on and perfect your sex life with your partner and express what you need
and want and teach each other what's necessary to keep things exciting and,
and,
and new.
It's not an easy thing to do,
but it's very much worthwhile because then you can combine sexual excitement
with intimacy and there's no better combination than that.
So I'd love that can all be a nested up inside love and inside,
uh,
you know,
a destiny that's intertwined together and that's the best you've got man.
That that's,
that's,
that's what life has to offer.
And so,
um,
that's what you do is you accept the responsibility of the next stage of life
and you don't mourn the past.
I suppose that also means that when you're young,
you do what young people do and so that you don't want to do it again.